[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and welcome to the
chapter review for my hero academia
chapter 161 to be honest I don't even
know how to start off this review I'm
just gonna say right now major spoilers
ahead if you haven't yet read the
chapter be warned
major spoilers are coming this chapter
is called a bright future and guys I
think this chapter might have just
changed everything it might have been an
important milestone that changes
everything about the future of boku no
hero as a whole I will talk about that
more later on in the video if you
enjoyed these reviews be sure to leave a
like to let me know and if you're new be
sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell if you want to be
notified every time that I post a new
review and now let's get into it this
chapter starts off with the aftermath of
the battle between the eight precepts of
death and the heroes while a lot of
heroes and cops were injured and a lot
of material damage was done thankfully
only three civilians were injured and
not that severely meanwhile in the
hospital the doctors are looking after
the heroes and the students and we
learned that Deku Aizawa Kirishima
ammaji ma la crock and fat gam were all
injured to various degrees but they are
all going to be fine
however arey is still unconscious and
suffering from a fever so she has to be
quarantined and is being watched closely
and of course the reason area is being
quarantined is because she can't control
her quirks so everyone is afraid that
she might hurt someone if she comes into
contact with them and Aizawa points out
that Ares rewinding work appears to work
only on people not objects and at this
point just as I'm thinking okay what
they're saying is a few people were
injured but this is a shounen afterall
and everyone is going to recover which
by the way is the same thing I thought
about the last chapter when she kuraki
said he wouldn't kill or halt I was like
oh well he'll just use the bullets to
erase his squirt but everything will
stay family-friendly and then she got
rocky freakin cutoff overhauls hands in
this chapter we again see that know my
hero academia is quick
becoming far more mature and far more
serious than it used to be we see that
all mite has arrived at the hospital
because sir night eye is not doing well
in fact he is on his deathbed and there
is seemingly nothing that the doctors
and nurses can do to save him
Deku and all might rush to see sir night
eye and they tell him that he has to
hang in there he has to pull through sir
tells them that for a long time he had
been racking his brain on how to change
all mites fate because he had foreseen
him dying it seemed like no matter what
sir did the things he saw always came
true and he felt like these things were
impossible to change and that was always
stuck in the back of his mind you could
only imagine how terrible that must have
been for him seeing all of these bad
things are going to happen but being
haunted by the belief that he can't do
anything to change it no matter what
however sir says that Deku showed him
that changing fate was possible
Deku had such a clear vision and wish
for what he wanted to happen that he
managed to change everything with the
help of everyone else who focused their
wishes and energy into that same goal
sir tells Deku that the future is never
certain and that it was Deku who changed
his mind about that which is something
that sir is very grateful for and you
can just imagine that he is after all
the time he spent torturing himself and
racking his brain about the fact that he
seemed helpless to stop bad things from
happening this is an incredibly
important revelation for sir Knight I
and we can't overstate how much this
changes his perspective on everything we
then see a still injured media burst
into the room even though he shouldn't
even be moving and yet he begs and
pleads with Sir to pull through and not
die me do tell sir that he taught him
everything that he knows and he owes
everything to him and that he has to
keep teaching him and that he can't die
and this is such an emotional and
powerful scene we know what media has
been through how hard he had worked to
master his quark which is incredibly
and painful to control and now his
mentor and friend is dying in front of
him and in this scene media looks
completely broken down
it is really tragic and difficult to
even watch sir tells me do that even
though when he first took him on he
thought media would just be a fitting
vessel
since then media has become his most
treasured student and he is becoming an
outstanding hero and sir Knight I also
says that this is the only future that
they shouldn't change and he tells me do
to keep smiling and then in that moment
we see sir Knight I flatline and pass
away this is how the chapter ends and we
are left with these words his day ends
with a peaceful smile on his face
good night night I and wow just wow what
a powerful scene and what a powerful
chapter this moment marks a major
transition in my mind this is no longer
just a lighthearted manga for teens this
is now a truly mature and serious story
sir Knight eye is gone everyone is in
tears medio deku and all mine are
devastated but Sir died with a smile on
his face because deku showed him that
his worst fears were not true after all
that we can change fate and we can make
a difference if we do our best and try
hard enough maybe all might can be saved
after all this future which will
continue without sir Knight I is still a
good and bright one and shouldn't be
changed because there is still so much
hope just looking at deku and media how
they're maturing into remarkable heroes
along with Kirishima and so many others
this tells me that despite Sir Knight I
sacrifice the future is bright the
future is full of hope and this is
exactly why the title of this chapter is
a bright future and these three words
say so much it is truly poetic I really
do think that this chapter will end
being a major moment in this manga with
sir Knight igon things will never be the
same again his sacrifice will stay with
deku medial all might and the others
forever things will never be the same we
are entering a new more mature and
serious era of boku no hero for better
or for worse let me know what you guys
think did this chapter just change
everything what are your thoughts on
what just happened and where do you
think the story will go from here let me
know down below I love to hear from you
this is really one of those chapters
that just makes you step back and say
wow did this really just happen so much
emotion so much drama there's no going
back from this and yeah it's just so
powerful if you enjoyed these reviews be
sure to leave a like to let me know if
you're new to the channel don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell if you want to be notified whenever
a new review is uploaded as always thank
you so much for watching rest in peace
sir Knight I and until next time see us
bass cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]